وقد قال الرئيس الفرنسي منويل ماكرون
بلاده لن تمنح اوكرانيا طائرات مقاتله
مؤكدا في مقابله مع القناه الفرنسيه
الاولى ان ذلك ينسجم مع الموقف المبدئي
لفريسه الداعم لاوكرانيا في صمودها في وجه
ما سماه العدوان الروسي والرافض في نفس
الوقت منحها القدره على استهداف الاراضي
الروسيه
على صمود يجب ان يتم الان وبكثافه لان
نجاح هذا الهجوم المضاد سيكون له انعكاس
على امكانيه بناء سلام دائم الامر الثاني
هو الا ندخل في حرب مع روسيا فقط ان نساعد
اوكرانيا على الصمود في وجه العدوان
الروسي وهذا يعني الا نمنحك اسلحه يصل
مداها التراب الروسي نستمر في التقدم وفي
دعم اوكرانيا على الصمود اعتقد ان تكوين
العسكريين الاوكرانيين وتطوير القدره على
استخدام المعدات التي قدمناها هو الاهم
والان الى جانب هذا سنسلمهم معدات واليات
وصواريخ اخرى بمدى يسمح لاوكرانيا بالصمود
وبشن هجومها المضاد
لنكن واضحين هل فرنسا ستسلم طائرات
لاوكرانيا
لم اتحدث عن طائرات تحدثت عن صواريخ وعن
تكوين